it's that time of year again that's
right summer finals are here across
every region teams are not only fighting
for a domestic title before a shot to go
to Worlds as the first seed this is the
time when big players set up to make big
plays so we've decided to put together a
list of the top ten game changing plays
during a Finals matchup and League of
Legends kicking off our list is bald
Turtle Series winning Quadra kill during
the 2014 na LCS summer finals against
cloud nine not much damage from the
shockwave but the control TSM needs to
reassess the fight boss gets hit up the
glacial fissure on the backside
they bottleneck into this fight and our
coma trip bro Pikul did tries to get his
outfit down left glass breath has
already been used coming up with focus
whoa
[Applause]
even with the kills even because the
fight was so close to carve a space this
could be the end of the series
our ninth spot goes to a HQ for their
brilliant turn off baron against Hong
Kong's eSports during the 2015 LMS
summer finals una thing something on the
home so this is a patient face on the
tall way oh that's a good with its
inoculated agencies in you with a sharp
words that's the face on quizzes that
your Queens that known to achieve a lot
over gamma
I like the block so these mountains I
was until I saw the dirt
sure Phase III do you see the top all
the fences it's already a little bit see
what yeah what about so maybe check out
Casa de mis amigos
[Applause]
we can't talk about finals and not
mention the rivalry between SKT and the
Tigers and so our number eight spot goes
this explosive game-winning fight from
the 2016 lck spring final corrode now
pulling the trigger on that e bang goes
it down to pray that's a lot of damage
pray lives though and SK Telecom could
be in trouble to go back for the kill
gets it on to rat
Kuro Sapp by Baker at SKT turning this
fight around Kirill on his own and
there's a double kill bird to SK Telecom
looking at an inhibitor bang didn't even
know Frey was there I guess not
he was ambushed and he just ended up
hitting him with some skill shots from
Ezreal really unfortunate but bang and
right in the face of that twitch makes
it work sticks a super clean triple kill
against TSM comes in at number seven
that's number three the traps are
already up there already there too soon
for some spot then here comes on sir
looks for the play gets head-butted it
gets pulverized around there knocking
sticks a but he's gonna be alright with
it I wonder now a ton frontline hunts
are taking so much damage gonna get
saved by qunit for now now they've got
to wait for the rapid fire to be back up
then goes to them against man's grip
where's the flash away shot and ta get
popped around knocked back now by Buster
shot as well piercing his lungs foggy
days ahead he gets it up but yours is
out he's still gonna try to read it all
we did for the resets
he's going
Smith these popping up from his gh
offense character try stuff but he's
with CLG and TSM being neck and neck for
40 minutes in game 5 6 a smart mechanics
carried CLG to their second LCS title
our sixth spot goes to long Jiu gaming's
Khan from the recent 2017 summer final
against SKT my god is going to survive
but he couldn't do anything against the
gigantic still turning away plan they
can at minimum get true and evidence
here but if I try to in the game they
can just go for the game they've got the
Baron buff still rotating around them
Khan manages to stay alive during a
crucial teamfight cementing long Jews
win over the defending champions holding
the door at number 5 is team w YZ insane
teamfight and backdoor safe during the
2017 LPL spring finals nail biting from
start to finish the ear of Jo who
whistled past and
nine five seven take a bit of that money
off to the side trying to find you got a
phone they have found it gets tougher as
well from the song applause Emeril goes
blank
orangey Fonzie still alive but Susie is
still not dead down into Ghajini what
they may have to do that one I've seen
here is mango seven is pressing forward
Ming as well will be falling press last
two kills let me back you away it's too
big but a massive plate coming in from
Xiao Liu takes away she ain't from the
fields of justice but look at the base
[Applause]
trans defend but let me he's no one help
no and everything but he's pushing with
everything he has left nine five seven
trying to make it back to base but
shallow and oozy stopping it all go
Pecos best dictator up there pushing
into this base daggers the first Nexus
turret kitchen one sir
he's an OG
to second exoteric for wel the nexus in
their sights they helped see a midseason
Invitational in their sights
w we jump on to the next show
to
bring blitz champion
reset hopping into fourth is reckless as
pentakill against origin during the 2015
new LCS summer finals playful tricksters
forward and the to mad tones on the
front line of origin forces the
defensive onslaught of shadows
so as ride the lantern out and these
hooks promise ya will keep the tower
alive ray never was in trouble because
yellow star I'm not that torn Miffy
wild growth will slow them down little
art connects as well and there are few
better ways to completely stuff a push
than whisset pentakill and the fact that
reckless did it in front of his hometown
Swedish crowd makes this play all the
sweeter
stealing's a third spot is smeb's
legendary baron steel against katie
during the 2016 lck summer final the
members of haiti where all rocks lakers
caught though Kiko
hang on the outside someday the one
taking a lot of hits gorilla bit low
though curtaincall gonna try to finish
him up that also way from the fight
curtain Cold Steel
fly gets killed Katie turns immediately
on the Baron can they take it out though
it's still risky
remember Rox Tigers fighting for their
tournament life here fighting for my
ferret taken Cal score misses smite by
only two HP it's undoubtedly one of the
greatest game-changing barons deals ever
the Rox Tigers secured their first-ever
lck Taito thanks to this play number two
on our list goes to deft and his
absolutely unreal pentakill against LGD
during the 2015 LPL spring finally
finally makes me think of me getting
tanked up as well clearly I've actually
died this born goes back enum acres not
here in depth now peeled away but Cora
does so much work in the fracture but it
might not be enough it would need
somebody killed to anybody qss is out
and gets the kill
that's two kills death goes back in
flashes aggressive bone needs to hide
away yes
what the hell gets a triple kill gets a
quarter gets a pentakill what on earth
is going on this nearly flawless
teamfight from death is magic to watch
and was the nail in the coffin as EDG
claimed the title our number one spot
goes to none other than double lift
during the 2016 na LCS summer finals for
his mind blowing performance on lucian
in a crucial team fight against cloud 9
booth is gonna trade his life as well
though four versus four no supports
alive no guardian angel for me Dios
whereas TSM still have two in two years
wall we resolve itself a couple now can
they have the follow-up damage a couple
of
man they've got Gibson and they shut up
dammit a 1,600 damage print can again
double low medium cinema document you'll
almost never see an ad carry play a team
fight this well while under extreme
pressure and of course double lift was
more than a match for the challenge so
those were our picks for the top 10 game
changing plays during a Finals matchup
in league of legends which one is your
favorite play let us know in the
comments section below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button
you